ch la distancia vertical entre las
gráficas se fije de la región e se
encuentra la razón de cambio de h con
respecto a x para x igual a 1.8 entonces
aquí está la región s y en esta región
puedes ver que la función f está por
encima de la función g entonces podemos
escribir a hdx igual a efe de x menos gx
y queremos encontrar la razón de cambio
de h con respecto a x para x igual a 1.8
entonces podemos escribir eso como h
prima de 1.8 porque es lo que queremos
encontrar la razón de cambio de h con
respecto a x para x igual a 1.8 ahora
para hacer eso también podrías sacar las
derivadas de las funciones y evaluarlas
en 1.8 pero bueno cuando tú estás
haciendo un examen a p ya tienes contigo
una calculadora la cual puede integrar y
evaluar derivadas entonces no hay
necesidad de que hagas tanto trabajo en
papel entonces cuando en el examen
quieran que encuentres el área o evalúes
una integral definida
evalúes una derivada en un punto puedes
usar tu calculadora ahora ya hemos
estado trabajando con hdx que es la
diferencia entre las funciones de fx gdx
recuérdalo lo hicimos para el inciso a y
b entonces ya tenemos esa información
guardada en la calculadora
en la parte a había hemos definido esta
función que es hdx tome el valor
absoluto es la única diferencia lo único
diferente que hice por lo que siempre es
positivo en cualquier región pero yo
puedo eliminar el valor absoluto también
eliminó este paréntesis y bueno ahí
tienes a hdx tenemos f x que es 1 x más
y elevado a la x al cuadrado menos 2x y
a eso le restamos gx y como estamos
haciendo la resta todos los signos de la
función g x van a cambiar de negativos a
positivos y viceversa entonces tengo
menos x a la cuarta más 6.5 x al
cuadrado menos 6 por x menos 2 y ahora
eso es como definía y sub 1 ahora cambió
de pantalla y entonces ya puedo evaluar
esta derivada cuándo x es igual a 1.8
entonces voy a matemática bajó a n
derivada ahí está lo seleccionó
y voy a tomar la derivada de jesup uno
que ya había yo definido
entonces voy a variable
variable de ahí esta función selecciona
la función
1 ahí está
y entonces tomó la derivada del sub 1
con respecto a x
voy a evaluarlo cuando x es igual a 1.8
y obtengo
una aproximación de menos 3.812 y listo
terminamos por lo tanto h prima de 1.8
es aproximadamente menos 3.812 ahora
todo este ejercicio y sus incisos son
para ver que también entiendes los
conceptos de derivada e integral y ver
como como aplicas esto para resolver
problemas si entiendes bien esto y
tienes una calculadora a la mano
entonces este tipo de problemas en el
examen no te ocasionarán problema alguno